SCP-682 Vs The Gate Guardian.
Can the giant warrior with a
sword hotter than the sun finally
kill the Hard to Destroy Reptile?
When SCP-682 was brought in to hopefully
meet its ultimate destruction at the Gate
the Guardian Guards, it quipped,
“Is this meant to be the Garden?
This is not the Garden. The
Garden is far west of here.”
When the Gate Guardian struck 682, it was
grievously wounded, with only a single leg left.
As it regenerated, it snarled at the Gate
Guardian, saying, “Die? You command me
to die? Oh, wouldn't we all like that, but
this is my curse for suggesting the fruit.”
It struck again, and before passing
out from its injuries, 682 said,
“This is not the Garden, and
you are not Uriel. Pretender.”